the most important thing we can do as
people who are trying to make creative
work is to be yourself and uh embrace
what is uniquely you and
your own voice people who want to hire
you are looking for something new i know
that there is this idea that like
studios want the same yes and no it's
like comfortable enough but also
we've never seen it before what's very
important to me when i begin writing a
piece is to not have a
a message uh to not have um any
intention beyond staying true to the
world in which i'm trying uh to to write
in what is story uh balanchine once said
when he was being criticized for doing
choreographic pieces that were abstract
you know if a man takes a woman's hand
what more story do you need my brothers
when they read the script for the first
time said well you know i know that
they're speaking uh early modern english
but it sounds like our family art
you know you can't be judgmental of the
characters and the time period you can't
uh rewrite history to to conform to the
zeitgeist but you do have a
responsibility to understand what's
going on today and not be foolhardy my
inspiration uh often comes from research
i'm researching and writing in tandem so
i'm you know i research enough to write
some more and then i research enough to
write some more if you think about
writing it in an achievable way you're
not going to write it so just write it
and you'll figure it out
and you have to be blind to the
realities of shooting to tell the best
story
[Music]
the most important thing we can do as
people who are trying to make creative
work is to be yourself and uh embrace
what is uniquely you and your own voice
so obviously i'm just talking about uh
my approach and uh
and i
and it's and it's unique to the kind of
strange interests
that i have
and i i just hope that there's some
tools that you can put in your toolbox
uh that can work with
how you are you you have to like find
your own voice it's okay to start out
being derivative
because that's how we become ourselves
but but what you know
people who want to hire you are looking
for something
new i know that there is this idea that
like
people won't like like studios want the
same and there's and it's like yes and
no you you know it's like it's like
comfortable enough but also
we've never seen it before a few things
that i think about and struggle with
uh is trying to find a harmonious
balance of certain opposites in in my
writing uh the the the the largest
things would be like i you know
dionysian versus apollonian the sort of
um
or i'll start with apollonian which is
you know the the the structure the uh
what what patriarch or patriarchal
western culture would call like male
ideals and then the diet the dionesian
uh female
mysterious the uh
stuff like how do you create a balance
of something that is like rigorous and
structured and and and clear but also
has enigma and and mystery and
atmosphere i'm sorry to admit but i
don't tend to get writer's block
and that's because
uh i
i'm so research focused so if i'm
feeling stuck i can just pick up a book
and read a sentence that's inspiring or
even sometimes misread a sentence that's
inspiring and can get me
uh going i'm researching and writing in
tandem so i'm uh you know i research
enough to write some more and then i
research enough to write some more my
inspiration uh often comes from research
uh i think
you know different stories come about in
different ways
um
very often i start with a an atmosphere
uh that is uh
a an imagined
tactile atmosphere but also a visual
atmosphere of of a world
uh that i want to explore and then i try
to find a story that can accompany that
so
um
with the witch for example i remembered
that my as a kid like really thinking
about the idea weird kid
maybe that people who grew up in the
reign of queen elizabeth were like
walking around in the woods behind where
i grew up and that atmosphere and the
sense of dread and
and and a real witch
uh
you know that was exciting to me so then
research research research to then find
a story that can accompany that
atmosphere and what's very uh important
to me when i begin writing a piece is to
not have uh
a message uh to not have um any
intention beyond staying true to the
world in which i'm trying uh to to write
in um so but but but thank heavens like
as much as i try to seal myself up like
an anchor right uh or and lock myself in
my alchemical
cell uh
you know
the world is not my world is not vacuum
sealed so i am affected by the zeitgeist
whether i want to be or or not and if
and that's important because otherwise
you know the witch can't just appeal to
people uh who are alive in the 1630s and
the lighthouse can't just appeal to
people who are live in the 1890s because
there's not enough graveyard screenings
for that to be profitable um
uh so you know with the witch
um
uh i i'm i'm happy that that that most
people though not everyone for sure uh
sees the film as a feminist film if i
were to be objective and stand back i
think i would agree with that stance uh
but that was not my intention i just
wanted to make a witch movie as i kind
of said and and and but but but but
that's what happened with with the
lighthouse which i don't know if people
have seen um you know i was just trying
to make a ghost story in the lighthouse
uh which it's finally not but it became
you know when i was writing this story
this hyper masculine story about two men
with my brother i was thinking this is
why are we writing this right now this
is the worst time to be writing this
story and then once we had the first
draft we realized like oh i guess we're
talking about toxic masculinity and like
everything that's like uh
messed up about it so uh so that's
that's cool um
and uh you know but but but but but even
still when you're getting into this this
other world you know you can't be
judgmental of the characters and the
time period you can't uh rewrite history
um to to uh
to to conform to the zeitgeist but you
do have a responsibility to understand
what's going on today and not be
foolhardy uh the the thing that i'm
working on currently has slavery and
violence against women and uh and it's
takes place in the viking age so that's
gonna happen but how do i
tell those stories without rewriting
history responsibly
i don't you know those are the questions
i have to ask myself and i can't provide
easy answers what is story uh balanchine
once said when he was being criticized
for doing
like choreographic pieces that were
abstract you know if a man takes a
woman's hand what more story do you need
uh
you know i think um
in america
even more than britain but also in
britain more than
continental europe there is this kind of
like traditional narrative dramaturgy
that is held by
many
film students and and critics to be
uh what
what is good you know
and having these kinds of turning points
and
three act structure or five act
structure or whatever it is
uh and and your
and how you play by those rules and tell
the story
is uh what makes you a good storyteller
but of course that's absurd uh you know
i mean uh from
you know
shakespeare's corleanus is
not
the best way to tell that story like the
way the scenes come together but it's so
well written that it's incredibly moving
and that's
like the form in in in doing this kind
of archetypal storytelling even if it's
based on a fairy tale or a myth i still
try to bring in
you know my my personal experiences the
things that that are me when my brothers
first read uh the witch screenplay they
said you know even though this is the
17th century it sounds like our family
arguing you know um
and that's and that's that's very
important you know someone um
not just conveying plot but but but also
having little um
asides
that are about life like these kinds of
things can of course
uh ground it so i think you know you the
the there is a scene
where um
uh
the mother and the father are having a
disagreement that could be
my parents disagreement or could be me
and my wife's disagreement and but it's
just spoken uh within with an older
uh
different dialect but it's the same
conversation
uh and i think
um and i i i don't
except for when i'm trying to convey
certain points of exposition i i very
rarely
uh translate
from
from i don't like write modern dialogue
and then translate it i'm a writer and
director so the way that i write my
screenplays is
would be inappropriate if i weren't
directing them
as as an actor who recently turned down
a role in one of my movies
said
uh that the screenplay was overwrought
uh and
and there is a kind of indulgence um in
the the details of my screenplays that
would be entirely foolish if i was
writing for another director there's a
level of specificity in the the blocking
uh you know if willem dafoe wears his
reading glasses like this if robert
pattinson scratches his ear like this it
may very well be in the screenplay
there's never uh
in my screenplay rome burns or they
fight you know arthur draws excalibur he
thrusts towards the giant who parries
and you know the whole
thing
so um
so there how important do you think
historical accuracy is to filming events
from the past well it's not important to
filmmaking
at all really and uh and you can make a
great period story
without being accurate you know
coppola's
dracula is one of the best designed
movies in my opinion but it's not
accurate at all but this is something
that i like for whatever reason one of
the things that it does
is that it creates that cuts out a lot
of decision making because everyone
knows what the bar is it's accuracy for
the most part i think that if i was
gonna be super strict there was things
that i would not have done but you need
to have a little bit of variety in the
look of things virtually no viking
helmets from the period have been
discovered
like so you can't have everyone with
literally the same exact helmets that's
the only one that's been discovered so
you have to find a way to make educated
guesses about like different versions
based around that they're inspired by
the periods nearby
that kind of thing um i made a short
film called brothers that was a proof of
concept to try to get the witch financed
um
i had been many years since i made a
short film and my most recent work was a
very stylized piece based on edgar allan
poe which featured a puppet as a lead
character and
performances that were truly weird
and
my producer said you know if you want
anyone to finance the witch you probably
ought to make a new short and it should
feature uh naturalistic performances by
children
um and scary woods
um
and so that was a task you know and and
so and and thus i was able to find a
story that uh met with that pragmatic
task yeah i mean the the aspect ratio um
it got a little smaller over the years
but but i always wanted it to be boxy
and i always wanted to be black and
white 35 millimeter that's something
when i that i saw when i pictured the
atmosphere
and of course
like as you move forward both in the
writing and then in development and then
in prep you learn more things change you
know and your preconceived notions
are not always correct but uh but but
you find you make choices that are
closer to your original intentions even
if they weren't your preconceived
notions about how to articulate your
intention uh and
yeah so sometimes i
i see
how it's shot and and sometimes in
certain sequences i write extremely wide
shot lighthouse tender like in the
middle of the sea yada yada like
close shot the hull carves through waves
like bubba but sometimes i'll do that
which again as a writer director i can
get away with because it's a terrible
thing to do otherwise
um
and sometimes i see that and i don't
write it because it's distracting to the
flow of the scene
sometimes i just see a scene a story and
i know that we're gonna have to find it
later
sometimes
i see a scene with that's a complicated
action sequence or stunt or
a visual effect or practical effect and
i think okay how can i write this in an
achievable way and sometimes i think
if you think about writing in an
achievable way you're not going to write
it so just write it and you'll figure it
out
and you have to be blind to the
realities of shooting to tell the best
story
you